on this episode I get really pissed at
the lurkers
[Music]
huh
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 129 on
the ask gary vee show i'm in a good mood
it's it's Friday
yes it's Friday thanks my glob good to
see you
excited getting into the weekend should
be a lot of fun got a couple of uh
Wuzzles in the house actually you know
what you rock real quick just shoot
right over there to that little sign
just want people to take a look at that
just maybe because super random the
other thing I want to do before I get
into the show is to uh throw a dramatic
right hook here right now I feel like a
lot of the lurkers specifically watching
in facebook have not been leaving
comments have not been coming out of the
Woodworks have not been saying hello
right I also feel that a lot of people
have been watching the show I see the
numbers and the amount of comments and
shares and likes which that helped me
get distribution in a Facebook newsfeed
world are way too low as a matter of
fact Facebook live people right now if
you're watching you can share comment
and like especially the share button
I want more distribution I want the show
to grow I don't know right hook Steve I
mean I think it's fair it's a free show
I feel like I'm PBS I'm the modern PBS
right I'm not charging I just need some
support and things really pissing me off
is there are people actually this is
back-channel information I have
conversations I've had some random
emails people actually are not sharing
this show are not hitting the share
button right now that is a yes I want
you to hit the share my man eclectic
share button see every single person
that shared and anybody that didn't
share that I know has been watching the
show I'm going to kill you
so am I allowed to say that that would
legal be a little worried about that I
was dirty alright you know what
d-roc when I said kill you there put a
little asterisk mean I'm just kidding I
would never kill you um but uh there are
people that are actually not sharing the
show because they want to use the
information as their secret sauce can
you imagine
pretty easily imagine yeah yeah well
that's cuz you you you're not saying I
do it I'm just saying it's not
inconceivable oh no I'm not saying that
that's why you're saying it I'm saying
it's because you're you're you're
cynical to the audience you actually
hate the audience that you just took a
really big lead between Gary I'm just
but share they write do something
they're like actually you know what I
want you to create something right now
edit this and then we'll use it all the
time
and one night when you edit it the rock
give like fire and like crazy stuff
share alright India alright India yeah
you'll see what this all was in a
separate video that d-roc made me do I
hate this we're definitely never doing
this again
like I'm doing something I hate I don't
even do this at like oh yeah India let's
get into the show good job India alright
clintus clintus asks when your business
is successfully growing when do you
start another and how much time you
devote to it um I think it comes down to
who you want to be as an operator Travis
Cal connect CEO of uber really taught me
a lesson a couple years ago when uber
was starting to take off he became the
CEO we did angel deals together and I
was picking him about this hot angel
deal and he said no I don't do angel
deals anymore and then I pinged him out
a talk and he goes no I'm not gonna talk
and like it was just very focused and
and and then you know he's basically in
that Bezos Steve Jobs sucks mold which
is is it is it this is the job I'm gonna
do for the rest of my life and this is
my career
I already clearly am on my second you
know
roofie business I think I've got two
more three more in me and so I'm gonna
be an entrepreneur that has you know
four or five businesses is my intuition
India clintus and so i think i think
comes down to you who you are right and
what you want like what's the size level
of a business that gets you to go into a
different place I mean vaynermedia next
year revenue wise is going to
substantially probably pass wine
library's biggest year of revenue so
I'll be going into new territory is it
do I start
in my entrepreneur that likes that 50
100 million
a revenue place and I I go away or am I
going to see like it really just comes
down to a lot of different circumstances
I do think that you need to question the
question which means if you're already
asking me this question and thinking
about going on to the next thing you
need to figure out how much you love the
current thing at all are you just trying
to pass it away I think there's a more
interesting insight to that I think
everybody was watching the show needs to
think about are they happy with their
business is that you know there's
businesses that you could be making
$200,000 a year in that could be holding
you back um cuz it's a lot kind of money
you might just not like it and so I
think there's there's the like factor
you know for me I will run this business
vaynermedia as CEO as long as I love it
that's really the answer I mean you know
I'm glad I got to stick here because I
kind of used a financial proxy as the
justification but to me it's as long as
I love it I mean and so it could be but
my intuition tells me I've got a couple
more so I think comes down to you uh and
I think it also comes down to
infrastructure if Brandon Warnecke and
Justin Novello and Bobby Schifrin and
John cosmos and and Brian Bell Torian
Jeff the Rose if they weren't in place
at Wine Library along with my dad I
would still be there you know
vaynermedia I mean some of you've been
here for a while vaynermedia is a hell
of a lot of better shape today for me
not to be around than it was a year ago
I mean a hell of a lot we've gotten
dramatically more senior people have
grown but I think it's still maybe a
couple years away before I can feel like
it can sustain and grow without me and
so that is also the practicality of
these decisions matters as well any wait
a minute how do we not talk about this
because we we talked about in real life
you know vaynernation look at this I
mean India I mean I you know talked
about kissing up to the boss
stunwin because you see uh India's gonna
go to a lot of jet games this year
taking on a lot of games okay that's
crazy India side question a day how many
football games have you been to in your
life I just want to see how many goose
eggs there are
hashtag Team India all right what did
you say this question from your dad the
best part about this is your email to me
is like you think it's okay to tell you
the question for your dad you're such a
you I really like your your morals it
would have been really really funny if
you just asked it so from John and like
slipped it in there
all right India's dad India's dad asks
how do I succinctly explain who you are
and what you do to people who don't know
you and our new media savvy how do I do
that
what Oh me oh man I wish this was the
ask Liz Evie show my life my life she is
my life my wife uh thinks this is the it
is literally her favorite thing because
you know we go to a lot of we go to
functions or meet some a new couple
they're like so what do you do and she
just gets a kick out of it because I
think your dad who's got some context of
me at this point
recognizes it's not that easy it's a you
know it's a long-winded answer at this
point I do say that I'm an entrepreneur
I think it just saves time but then
there's a part of me that feels like
that's a fluffy kind of answer and so I
also I also lately lately that's
actually not sure I was going
entrepreneur Oh Bob right now lately I'm
very hardcore on the CEO of a large
social digital agency and I'm the lead
partner in a twenty five million dollar
venture fund and I'm also the host of
the askgaryvee show I don't say that yet
but I'm starting I stuck it in the other
day so you know I love talking about
myself so I always love that question
and I drag it out for as long as they'll
keep listening and but that's what I've
been doing at this point
well it's cool that's an amazing picture
all right do you rock I'm sure you're
editing that in perfectly good job
digital Jeff asks how important is it to
love the product that your company sells
would you hire someone who had never
used your product and can being too much
in love with your own product work
against you you know to me look if you
talk we're talking about from a sales
standpoint um I think that this is
probably the bit
yeah battery nice yeah get univariant oh
do you be cool but this is rolling you
the whole time
now are they picking it up on the yeah
they're picking us all up right so this
is all rolling in black and white right
it's all black and white
yeah
alright internation let's do something
secret it's I've got a big idea let's
all hit up at the rock on Twitter right
okay see see this money headed to you so
yes oh I'm beyond I got Facebook live
eek rap dirac alright Facebook live how
many people are watching uh what 1800
perfect 1800 I want all 1800 of you to
do the following thing what's the Ruxin
got the rock my sarah kovin go back out
yeah we're kicking you out so we do
something that day the rock NYC David
Rock Port de bras on when the hey does
David and David Ross active David Rock
NYC just hit him up with like hash tag
audio fail and then a win gonna love cuz
he's the best guy okay alrighty rock
murari actually he's the best guy
alright back to you guys in black away
OD rock I love it he's so sad he's so
great like it's so much pride in skills
but yeah thank you rock thank you so
much classic this is the golden girl I
love it Oh batteries listen to just
batteries Antonio Allen was just cut by
the New York Jets one of my favorite
players of all time in New York and 39
he was cut this is Major
it's a rough game so Antonio thank you
so much for the years in green and white
number 39 much love um okay let's uh I
don't know where I was cuz the rock ruin
the show let's give that another try
Digital Jeff asks how important is it to
love the product that your company sells
would you hire someone who had never
used your product and can be too much in
love with your own product we're against
you yes I would tell you that it's the
single most important thing I think the
reason that I'm a great salesman is that
I really fundamentally believe in
everything that I'm selling the advice
here my books wine that I recommend I'm
about to do an Instagram wine offer for
the first time in a coupon right after
we tape this like idea I really I really
believe in this rose I doesn't I know
it's a little side thing sorry Steve
Steve's my wine boss um and so uh
hashtag wine boss
show him and show hashtag wine boss love
it um so we're cookie here on uh Friday
melee your faulty rock for the battery
thing um and so uh I can't wait for the
Edit of the voice Oh nobody oak monster
sales exactly when the share monster
comes out you have to stop what you're
doing and hit the share button on
Facebook all of you on live you have to
do that right now
Simeon turn tell have them say yes they
just did it and see how many yeses you
got me if you don't count to 1900 to
match the thing start yelling and
getting crazy in there alright you have
to sell what you believe in
the reason salesmanship has a bad name
is because 98 percent of sales people
don't believe in what they're actually
selling they're just going for the
Commission the money is what drives them
not the pride and the lifetime value of
selling something good when you sell
something you believe in you get so much
more money out of it because people come
back guys it's all about the second and
third and fourth and fifth and sixth and
seventh and eighth and ninth and tenth
and eleventh and twelfth and thirteenth
and fourteenth and fifteenth and
sixteenth and seventeenth and eighteenth
and nineteenth and twentieth sale not
the first one and what happens is if you
actually really believe in what you're
selling it gives you more conviction to
uh and believe that you're going to get
that sale and and I believe in that
tremendously I think that's why I think
a great salesperson somebody that truly
believes and are passionate about what
she or he sells is the number one kind
of person in the world and that's what I
focus on and so I think it is the
prerequisite to being successful - you
need to be blindly the way you think
children are the most beautiful and the
smartest that's the blind faith you have
to be having in what you sell others
part to the question
no no blind faith India okay you'll see
right background wait lipstick hey Gary
Vee its Kelsie Humphreys we are taking a
quick break from shooting the pursuit
and I thought I would send you a
question but I have to say you are
killing me because I keep recording
questions for you and then I go to post
it and you already posted like three new
episodes and for long Facebook post and
you answered my question so I hope that
this question makes it in to the golden
era oh well my question is about having
two different audiences and how you
juggle them for example the audience for
askgaryvee is very different from your
ideal client for vaynermedia yes and for
me an observation should get a lot of
opt-ins and a lot of traction and
comments from my audience when I talk
about how I'm still rookie and my show
is only six months old and I'm still
figuring out what I'm doing they love
that but I'm worried about potential
guests and potential sponsors not
wanting to work with someone whose
content is about how they're a rookie
and I think a lot of people deal with
this when they're trying to take their
client base to the next level but the
content that they've been putting
putting out is on the previous level so
tell us what to do about that Gary
Thanks you got it cows this is a very
easy question to answer for me the
answer is the part where I sell for
clients I'm selling them the services of
vaynermedia in the beginning my ability
now our agencies ability to help you
social media to drive business results
and that's just a separate entire
conversation from the content of this
show that is helping a lot of
entrepreneurs is not made for brand
managers and CMOS of Fortune 500 other
than the ones that are passionately
pursuing other interests
maybe financially or thinking about
outside the corporate environment and so
this is excuse more entrepreneurial and
things of that nature and I think that
you can't be crippled by that it sounds
like to me that in the way you asked
that it was a great question my
curiosity is are you using the show as a
gateway drug to clients that
for your rub is for me I'm not using
this show as that and so you know I'm
not concerned about having their very
church and state if you view that what
you're doing on this show or how you're
going about it is the same service that
you're then selling to a client well
then you've got a problem because you're
you're admitting to them that you're
only so far along the way and so me
being a personality around business
questions is very different than me
being an operating CEO of a large scale
social digital shop that that helps
clients execute creative and strategy in
those channels it ties in a little bit
because I use my tactics like long story
they're like fire you're right yeah to
you know learn what that means and then
maybe you know a Dove soap or Toyota can
use those tactics to make those things
happen but I think that's the disconnect
only one you need yeah you're the only
one I need what I need do you notice
what I said you're the only one I need
I'm amazing mom you mom you her mom you
you really brainwashed the [ __ ] on me
Celestine days only one you need asks
instead of doing a forum have you
considered using a private Facebook
group for the askgaryvee show cool
that's a great idea it's something that
I haven't I haven't done I noticed one
of the fans jumped in and created one
it's something that's run through my
mind um and actually I think this
question is gonna spur me to do it so at
the end of the golden era in episode 131
we will announce a private Facebook
group just so I can test it so that's
some work for you guys cool the question
alright hope you have a great weekend
question of the day is what are your
weekend plans lurkers if you know what a
lurker is you know watch while a bikini
a lurker is somebody who watches this
goddamn show siphons all the information
for free for themselves and doesn't have
doesn't have that gene in their body to
know that I am feeding off of not cash I
am feeding off of engagement content
shareability
all these nice things and so lurkers
please come out this weekend thus it's
the whole time please come out
YouTube lurkers all of you podcast
lurkers who haven't reviewed of lurkers
you're pissing me off
it's a right hook heavy ask Gary Vee
show you keep asking questions and
commenting or I won't answer them
anymore I'm really you know I think you
guys are getting my tone here right I'm
pissed the lurkers
they're like Patriot fans you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
hey Andy what's he doing it looks like
he's being very serious-looking his
phone I can crush Andy's head hey I got
your head hey crushing your head crush
it yeah amazing all right
[Music]